we as conservatives do the most horrific
job at uh reaching out to the black
community it's like and i mean you know
it's not only on us but it's the fact
that it's like when we get called racist
we say well our fiscal policy is very
yeah exactly it's like it's like it's
like exactly right it's like instead of
calling somebody an for calling
you racist white supremacists you know
whatever um you're speaking my language
so how do we combat that by calling them
an i mean like really that's
that is the actual answer if someone
calls you a racist without evidence this
makes them technically in the dictionary
parliament's an like it really
that and it's not appropriate to have a
conversation if someone calls you a
racist with no evidence your proper
response should not be well that's
reasonable let's have a conversation
about this because once you do that
you've acknowledged that a reasonable
person might think you're a racist which
means you're a racist right in the minds
of the public so you actually have to
you actually have to create a basic
mutual assured destruction which is they
call you a racist you say no you're just
you're just a jerk right and and then do
you want to actually have a conversation
about policy or you want a name throw
because i think you're ugly also